E aí
[Música]
Tá bom eu tenho duas certezas sobre você
a primeira que você vai morrer o dia
infelizmente isso todo mundo sabe e a
segunda é que você já ouviu falar em
Bitcoin pelo menos uma vez no último ano
o último ano foi o ano que a gente mais
passou tempo na internet foi o primeiro
ano que a humanidade passou mais tempo
no digital do que no presencial e nesse
mesmo ano o Bitcoin O dinheiro criado na
internet passou de algo totalmente
criticado E desacreditado pela grande
maioria algo a ser estudado e a ser
regulado pelas grandes autoridades uma
valorização de quase quatrocentos e
vinte por cento e sendo alvo de diversas
polêmicas e notícias ao redor de todo
mundo
é mas afinal o que é o Bitcoin
é bom segundo lugar swifter Bitcoin é um
dinheiro intangível criado na internet é
um tipo de commodity criptográfica o
melhor e mais revolucionário do Bitcoin
é que ele não tem nenhuma autoridade em
um emissor nenhuma instituição por trás
dele ele foi proposto por um pseudônimo
em 2008 E desde lá foi totalmente
desenvolvido e aprimorado pela própria
comunidade além de trazer uma grande
revolução para nossa economia sociedade
ele também trouxe uma grande revolução
tecnológica com a tecnologia do bote em
hipersuper
Oi e para entender essa tecnologia a
gente tem que entender um pouco mais
como funciona a internet convencional
que a gente usa hoje em dia vamos supor
que você mande mensagem para uma pessoa
Esse é um processo que eu tenho que
certeza que todo mundo faz diariamente o
fluxo de dados essa mensagem vai ser
basicamente esse ela vai primeiro para o
servidor da rede social da companhia que
está intermediando e depois ela vai
passar a pessoa que você manda mensagem
é claro que isso hoje acontece
milissegundos forma muito rápida e
eficiente mas o fato é que essa rede
social essa instituição fazendo o
intermédio ela tem posse das informações
as pessoas sabe que as pessoas estão
pensando
ela essas empresas são as empresas mais
poderosas do mundo e que mais ganham
dinheiro atualmente e o Bitcoin a
tecnologia do Botequim Corta tudo isso
da tecnologia do blog tem aplicar coisa
que você tem como espécie de intermédio
na a ação são os chamados de mineradores
que eles são responsáveis por
basicamente
autenticar a transação ver se ela é
válida ou não fora isso você não tem
nenhuma instituição por trás nada do
tipo e esse mineradores qualquer um pode
ser um minerador contanto que tem poder
computacional para isso
é mas beleza eu entendi a
tecnologia do bote entende o Bitcoin Mas
qual que é a utilidade disso porque que
as pessoas estão comprando é Bitcoin
porque as pessoas estão otimistas
tá bom alguns loucos acreditam que um
bicho ponha um dia pode se tornar uma
moeda de troca Mundial isso é muito fora
da caixa que se pensar mas não é uma
hipótese impossível
outras commodities que já foram usadas
como moeda de troca no passado como o
ouro e prata demoraram em média mil anos
para adotar a serem adotadas como moeda
de troca então descobriram o ouro e
depois de mais ou menos mil anos
adotaram ele como essas trocas e o
Bitcoin e levou apenas um ano então ele
começou a realmente rodar e na prática
em 2009 em 2010 a gente já tem registro
do rhaylan um americano que trocou uma
pizza por 10 mil bitcoins
Os outros acreditam que o Bitcoin é um
tipo de ouro digital que as pessoas vão
começar a realmente investir nas crises
para perder menos dinheiro
é mas apesar da sua utilidade de todas
as novas coisas que o Bitcoin trouxe Nem
tudo são flores a rede computacional do
Bitcoin e já gasta mais energia de
países como Argentina tem 44 milhões de
habitantes
é Mas se a gente for pegar um gráfico e
comparar a quantidade de energia gasta
com Bitcoin e com outros serviços que
ele supostamente substituiria como
sistema bancário e mineração de ouro
temos que ele ainda é econômico
mas a gente também tem que analisar esse
gráfico sob Outro ponto de vista ponto
de vista de impacto Impacto que cada uma
dessas atividades causou na história da
humanidade
sistema bancário foi muito importante
para o desenvolvimento eu não preciso
nem explicar e o a mineração de ouro fez
o ser humano em diversas situações e
atrás explorar e foi muito importante
para o rumo que a nossa humanidade tomou
e para chegar onde está hoje
bom E como que o Bitcoin pode mudar o
rumo da humanidade como ele pode causar
um impacto muito forte
é bom e daí eu te dou aqui um desafio
tente lembrar de algum momento que teve
a relevância que o Bitcoin teve forma
tão desse centralizada na história da
humanidade
é
bom você promete não vai lembrar de
nenhum né mas teve um movimento na
Europa no século 16 que agiu de forma
semelhante e conseguiu um impacto muito
forte foi o movimento protestante
movimento protestante também começou a
atrás pequenas polos intelectuais
pequenas figuras que ganharam relevância
e conseguiram crescer de forma de se
centralizada e desbancar uma expressão
muito poderosa da época talvez mais
poder a instituição mais poderosa da
história a Igreja Católica
Ah e assim como o momento do Bitcoin em
assim como o movimento protestante
momento o Bitcoin ainda sofre diversas
tentativas barragem de grande e grandes
instituições do sistema financeiro e ele
ainda continua consolidado como a
comunidade engajada e crescendo essa
comunidade
bom e se formos pensar em desse
centralização
vemos que a internet já nos trouxe isso
desde o começo desde o início
e vamos pensar em uma situação que eu
queira ter um grupo de pessoas que são
fãs de uma banda certo Se eu fosse fazer
isso 30 anos atrás eu provavelmente
Teria que criar algum Clube alguma
instituição e promover eventos para
reunir essas pessoas e hoje em dia eu
faço isso em cinco minutos e coloca uma
a pessoa que eu quiser para conversar
sobre essa banda é
em qualquer lugar do mundo que ela
esteja e a internet permitiu isso
Oi e o Bitcoin nada mais nada menos fez
do que trazer isso para o lado
financeiro se a gente for se a gente for
para entrar na realidade no nosso país
há sete meses atrás a gente vê que a
gente não conseguia transferir dinheiro
instantaneamente para uma pessoa que
morava na nossa casa e com Bitcoin e
isso foi possível desde 2009 em escala
global
oi e daí eu te pergunto você gostaria de
viver em uma sociedade mais desse
centralizada onde estivesse mesmo -
monopólio menos pessoas com muito poder
Centralizado bom o Bitcoin pode trazer
isso obrigado a
[Música]
E aí